yakuza like a dragon starts a brand new
story in the long-running yakuza
franchise
and it's an xbox series x launch game
here we have our gameplay from a demo
build running on the series x
in true yakuza fashion the charming
absurdity shines through
which you'll see in the karaoke mini
game and new rpg combat system
and yes we have baka mitai as of now
when running the game on the series x
you'll have a few enhancement options
such as high resolution mode
for true 4k that runs the game at what
looks to be around 30 fps
and high frame rate mode which brings
down the visual quality to run much
higher fps
i set the visuals to normal which is
what you see here and seem to hold a
consistent 60fps without sacrificing too
much graphically
we'll have more details on the xbox
series x soon but for now
enjoy gameplay from the delightfully
wild yakuza like a dragon
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
um
all right
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yay oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
time
[Music]
you